we are dave franco dave franco kamel
nanjani and fred armisen
and we are doing the wired auto complete
interview hey hi
hi
[Music]
is difranco it's an
interesting question these feel good are
these in order of most searched
i think so i don't like that where is
dave franco from
i am from the mean streets of palo alto
california
yeah dude yeah what is dave franco's
how do you think this question's gonna
what is dave franco's
uh something with my eyebrows i'm
thinking favorite color
blue okay
what's your favorite painting the mona
lisa geez it is
what is dear franco's
uh david john franco is dave franco
you're gonna you're gonna be shocked by
this answer um
yeah yeah i'm i'm late where is dear
franco
right now we're in legoland we're at
legoland
i also like that somebody was googling
where is dave franco
right now i want to go to dave franco
i like to think that it's the same
person who's like is dave franco white
yes okay so where is he
right now i want to talk to a white
person right now also why would google
know that there must be people working
overtime there at google do you think
that when you ask google a question
there's someone somewhere who gets the
question
and has to like look it up in a book and
then type it in
they go to yahoo and look it up
in mass effect andromeda what's
happening there it's a video game and
yes i am in it
i played jaron ten who's sort of like
the president of that
federation so yes let's come online
getting married
yep 10 years somebody was looking you up
like wonder if he's married
is kamel nanjing urdu no because urdu is
a language
so it'd be like is fred english i guess
that makes sense because that's also
nationality but it would be like
infrared sign language
yeah it's fred's sign language that's
yeah
that's tough that feels that is urdu
all right does fred armisen speak
spanish
venezuela so what's the answer
i said that i don't speak yeah yeah okay
does it fred emerson know american sign
language i'm sorry
i want to learn does fred armistead have
gauged and i think they mean ears
gauged ears no i don't you have a
character that does i have a character
that does
that's when i was never brother i have a
older half brother in
germany what's he like very german and
um
uh very organized and um very quiet and
oh no this is a tikka
no this is a coffee cup does fred
armistead vegan
i do you do vegan what
what zodiac sign is dave franklin uh i'm
a gemini
what does dave franco look like a lot
like that right
it's a lot like this do i look like
myself today you do actually let me see
let me see
oh yeah you look like dear franco i bet
you get that a lot
what time was different before that's a
good guy
i do love that question i don't i don't
know do you guys know what time you're
waiting for i don't know
i think 9 a.m like on the diet no i
think i'm 9 p.m
i don't know that's a huge difference
what
color are dave franco's eyes i would say
that it's
a easily really
i was gonna say like a fielded dusk
what is different favorite movie stand
by me okay
partially for nostalgic reasons it was
uh my first r-rated movie and then
partially because i love movies
with kids where the actors are actually
really good
how old is kamel ninja i'm 39 years old
how tall is kamel nanjiani
510 what does this say on your resume
rounding up from five nine and a half
you know
kamel nanjiani no i think i'm saying it
right
kamel nanchiani i think that's how it
how is that
how kamel nanjiani met his wife it's
true she heckled me at a comedy show
what did she yell out she just did like
a sarcastic woo-hoo
was she doing it in a flirty way i
certainly perceived it as being flirty
and it certainly was an icebreaker and
then we talked afterwards and one thing
led to another and we've been married 10
years
kamel nanjiani an uber driver now that
feels like it's a racist question
but i think it's about moving
because i could swear he was my driver
yeah i just commented on jenny working
at dunkin donuts
um no i was i've never been an uber
driver
there's more what high school fred
armisen go to
valley stream central high school what
movies has fred armisen been in
guys am i supposed to live somewhere no
don't
yeah go to imdb what band was fred
armistead in
first i was in a hardcore punk band
called the kgb and then i was always our
hit song oh we had no hit songs
we were at the bottom of the charts oh
your favorite song we
did a song called my school that was
very fast
all the rules my school all the things
what guitar does fred arms do you play
guitar you're a drummer
yeah but you know i'm a show-off i play
a guitar called the fano
do you play any other instruments a
little bass yeah mm-hmm
you can make you tickle the keys a
little bit a little bit let me see you
tickle again
there they are oh can you in post can
you add
notes script to c to c minor
back and forth thanks people are really
asking some
stupid questions on what was your
favorite question of all of them not
even posed to you
i i like the one that was asking me if i
was an uber driver but is dave franco
dead
is great it's different or dad he's not
dead then where is he
right now